ladies and gentlemen welcome back I am
joined by Ben Greenfield and we are
doing a special kovat 19 how to survive
episode so Ben what have you been doing
to prepare yourself and to keep yourself
as healthy as you can given the current
state of the world well I'm not an
immunologist or biologist or a physician
or anything like that and I know there's
so many people talking about you know
vitamin C and glutathione and
acetylcysteine and you know sticking
ozone up your ass but for me I I like to
come at things from just like a purely
ancestral standpoint I think that's
where we should start when it comes to
immune system modulation so I could tell
you that the non-negotiables for me the
past the past couple of weeks if I could
give you if I could give you three
things you know of course like you know
the hand-washing and social distancing
and ample amounts of sleep all you know
all those are lifestyle tactics that
make sense that people are aware of but
a this idea of breath work you know we
see examples like wim HOF who got
injected with e.coli was able to
modulate the cytokine response to that
via his pranayama esque breathing we
know that deep breathing through the
nose can can clean the nasal passages
warm the air which is naturally a little
bit more antiviral it can cause a nitric
oxide release which we know specifically
for coronavirus nitric oxide seems to
have a really good effect especially if
you have your vitamin C levels topped
off nitric oxide and vitamin C seem to
work very well together it down
regulates anxiety and stress because
when your nasal breathing it's very
difficult for the cortisol releasing
baroreceptors in your chest to get
activated I'm doing breath work every
day like 20 to 40 minutes of breath work
every day and I've kind of just in the
past couple of weeks
I've changed up my routine a little bit
I've actually taken the the afternoon or
early evening workout that I usually do
and I've shortened it to just about 15
minutes so I'm not doing a lot of the
soul-crushing exercise late in the day
which causes a little bit of an
inflammatory response
of itself and I've instead you know I'll
just I'll hit the Aerodyne and do like
you know whatever a quick too bad a
session and you know some burpees and a
quick 15-minute workout but then I go
straight into the sauna and I'm doing
about twenty to forty minutes of breath
work and I'm using a few different forms
of breath work but the one I'm using the
most is basically these rounds of of
what would be called intermittent
hypoxic breath work because hypoxia can
have a really good effect on the immune
system
so it's basically in two out two three
four in two out two three four and you
do that for about five to ten minutes
finish with a full exhale hold the
exhale as long as you can and then do
two to three rounds of that okay so it's
like a like a modified wim hof then ah
no because wim hof breath work is more
it would be like don't you it's a it's a
it's more like fire breathing and the
and that's different it's that's more
hyper oxic training and I'm doing is
more hypoxic training but then and I'm
still doing the wim hof stuff because
what I do is after I finish that I'm
also doing cold immersion and so I'll
finish that breath work go out by the
cold pool and do about three minutes of
wim HOF didn't get in the cold pool yeah
and so I'm kind of getting the best of
both worlds right like I'm getting the
the hyperox ik training or the hypoxic
training and then the hyperox it you get
from something like wim HOF so breath
work is number one guy number two number
two and three I've already kind of
alluded to number two is saw is heat
okay so we know we get the nitric oxide
release we know we get the heat shock
protein release we know we get that deep
immune enhancing sweat and detox effect
and so I'm in the sauna for a lot longer
these days like I mentioned I've
shortened my usual workouts and I
haven't said substitute with lots of
breath work and sauna so you know when I
start that 15-minute workout I turned
this on on so it's nice and hot when I
get in do the breath work in the sauna I
get a really deep sweat in and so
is one breathwork is another and cold is
amazing at modulating the inflammatory
response amplifying the activity of the
immune system down regulating the
cytokine response so after I finished
the breath work in the sauna I do about
three to five minutes of cold and I'm
also starting off the day with cold as
well so I'm getting to separate you know
three to five minutes kind of intense
intense bouts of cold at the beginning
and at the end of the day I've all my
clients doing this as well just on a
daily basis we've switched up the
workouts and change the harder workouts
the the more inflammation producing
workouts to be breathwork sauna and cold
so I for me those have been huge and you
know whether or not you get you know you
were talking about coronavirus or
anything else you know that's kind of a
cool practice to have normally that's
not something I do every single freaking
day but right now I'm doing that every
day just to keep my immune system
activated keep stress and anxiety at bay
and and so yeah I'd say you know
regardless of all the supplements and
fancy bio hacks and everything else I
think for most people breath work heat
and cold are pretty inexpensive pretty
available and that's that's where I'd
start I love it Ben thank you so much
man
[Music]
you